hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about resveratrol
and some recent insights into whether or
not we should be considering resveratrol
a friend
or a foe so firstly i'll talk about what
resveratrol actually is
and previous studies that show
resveratrol can extend lifespan
and then we'll look at the results from
this recent publication
that looked at resveratrol and tried to
get a better understanding
of the molecular underpinnings of
resveratrol in human cells
because you know it's always great to
know what these different compounds are
doing within our bodies
and then we'll take that information and
come up with an opinion about
whether or not resveratrol is really
good or bad for cells
so firstly then what is respiratory so
here
is a chemical structure of resveratrol
enzo resveratrol was a female propanoid
and it was first isolated from the roots
of the plant
for our trimble antiforum so it's a
naturally occurring compound
and it can be found in different foods
such as the skin of grapes blueberries
raspberries and also in peanuts
and so resveratrol is a phytoelectron
which is a class of compounds that are
produced by plants
under stressful conditions so this can
include being infected by pathogens or
being physically harmed such as by
cutting crushing or
irradiation so therefore resveratrol
is produced in greater quantities by
grapes
experiencing stress and i've taken this
quite from
david sinclair's book lifespan because
he mentions about resveratrol in this
book
and they believe the reason that plants
produce resveratrol
is evidence of xenohormesis the idea
that stress plants produce chemicals for
themselves
that tell their cells to hunker down and
survive
plants have survival circuits too and we
think we might have evolved to sense the
chemicals they produce in times of
stress as an early warning system
of sorts to alert our bodies to hunker
down as well
so the reason i mentioned that quote is
because later on in this video we'll
come to look at the results of this
recent publication
gene and wide screens revealed that
resveratrol induces
replicative stress in human cells and
the reason that there is a lot of
interest
in understanding resveratrol has come
from previous studies
that show that resveratrol can extend
lifespan in a variety of different
muscle
organisms such as yeast worms
fruit flies as well as mice when fed on
a high fat diet
and so because of these studies there's
a lot of interest in being able to
increase
resveratrol intake through diet by
taking
resveratrol as a supplement because if
you wanted to get the same level
of resveratrol as that used in infantry
studies
one study suggests that you would need
to drink 111 glasses of wine
but the interesting question is how is
resveratrol achieving
these increases in longevity what is it
actually doing to the cells
so probably the most purported mechanism
is
that resveratrol can increase the
activity of cert one
and set one is the situain and certains
are a family of nad plus dependent
enzymes
and they have a variety of different
functions within a cell but one of these
functions
is thought to be the activation of
stress resistance pathways
which might be an explanation to why
lifespan extension is seen in these
different modal organisms when given
resveratrol
but that's just one potential target of
resveratrol other studies
seem to suggest that resveratrol may
also act through
activation of a protein known as amp
kinase
and also by inhibiting another protein
cyclic amp phosphodiesterase but
irrespective of
the molecular underpinning of
resveratrol other studies show that
the cell-based level effect of
respiratory
seems to be a inhibition of cell
proliferation
and this is also evident from what david
sinclair
wrote about in this book lifespan he was
studying yeast
and yeast that had been given
resveratrol and what he noticed was
the resveratrol fed used were slightly
smaller and grew slightly more slowly
than untreated yeast
getting to an average of 34 divisions
before dying
as though they were calorie restricted
whereas normal yeast would only divide
about 25 times before it dies
however we are not used and still the
story with human cells
is still a little bit unclear so the
authors of this recent publication
wanted to further understand how
resveratrol can affect
cell proliferation and the way that they
did this was performing
a crispr cast 9 chemogenomic screen
in a human cell line so the human cell
line that they chose were nam sex cells
which is a b-cell leukemia cell line and
they gave them
the concentration of resveratrol that
partially
impairs cell proliferation of these
cells and then they induce this crispr
cas9 screen
and whilst that may sound a bit
complicated effectively what a crispr
cast 9
knockout screen is is in each of the
different cells
a different gene is effectively knocked
out and some of the cells depending on
which genes are knocked out
may grow better or that they may grow
even more slowly
and so over time cells that have knocked
out specific genes
will increase in the population and the
way that you can
identify which genes are being knocked
out is by sequencing the guide rnas that
were used to knock out the gene in the
first place
so i'm not entirely sure if that made
any sense
but effectively what the screen does is
that it enables chemical genetic
interactions between resveratrol and the
cells to be assessed
to give a better understanding of what
impact resveratrol is having in the
cells
so interestingly the authors found that
when
a set of genes were knocked out that
caused the cells to become sensitive to
resveratrol treatments and become sick
we're enriched for genes involved in dna
replication
and genome integrity and even more
interestingly
they also repeated this experiment not
using resveratrol but using
another drug known as hydroxyurea that
is a known inducer of replication stress
and there was considerable overlap
between the results
of the cell knockout screen with both
resveratrol
and hydroxyurea treatment so what does
this actually mean
well both bits of evidence suggest that
respiratory treatment
may be causing replication stress within
cells
and this was further supported by seeing
phosphorylation of a protein known as
check 1
which is part of the dna replication
checkpoint and this phosphorylation
event
occurred at similar kinetics where the
cells were given resveratrol or
hydroxyurea
so taking all the evidence together so
far it supported the viewpoint that
resveratrol treatment was inhibiting dna
replication
and so if we go back to the article that
i showed you briefly at the start of the
video
is resveratrol a friend or a foe the
reason that this question was asked is
because
inhibition of dna replication can result
in replicative stress
and replicative stress is a key driver
of genomic instability
that includes things such as mutations
in the dna dna rearrangements
and the occurrence of double-stranded
breaks in dna
and these features are early stages of
chemogenesis
and in fact replicative stress is a
hallmark of cancer and so
to quote from this article given the
interest in resveratrol
anterior still being a resveratrol
analog as putative nutraceuticals to
modulate lifespan
these findings are timely potentially
raising a word of caution on such
usage so what does all of this mean well
unfortunately
it's still a bit unclear firstly the
chemogenetic screen that they performed
didn't identify the two proteins i
talked about earlier
cert one and ampk and so this supports
the notion that resveratrol could be
impacting
several biological processes through
distinct molecular mechanisms
and so this most likely highlights one
of the limitations of doing these kind
of
chemogenetic screens and that you're
still using an infectro
cell line model which doesn't fully
recapitulate
what's actually seen in vivo whether
it's a model organism or human studies
and for these reasons it'd be more
interesting to see the response
of different cell types to respiratory
treatment
but it highlights definitely that we
still need more extensive mechanistic
studies to really understand the full
picture of how resveratrol is impacting
dna replication
but the second thing that's worth
mentioning is the dose of resveratrol
in this study they used 16 micromalar or
resveratrol when they treated the cells
this is more than six times higher than
a recent report that suggested a genome
protective benefit with low doses of
resveratrol
so therefore i think the best taken from
this paper
is best summarized in this article which
is the discoveries presented
really reinforced the importance of
considering the potential safety
concerns
of increased doses of these compounds
such as resveratrol
especially in people with increased
susceptibility to genomic instability
and so there may be a delicate balance
between the dose of resveratrol and
the potential benefits and adverse
effect of respiratory
and this is well summarized in this
figure here where you can see that maybe
at lower doses
there's interactions with these proteins
such as the sirtuins and ampk
that is giving this increased lifespan
in different model organisms
but at maybe higher doses it's causing
replication stress
which can result in dna damage and
genomic instability and so this study
also raises the importance of really
trying to understand
the bioavailability of resveratrol and
the
concentrations that the cells are being
exposed to as it's currently not clear
necessarily what dose is too high or too
low by just supplementation and
obviously would also depend on the
supplement itself
so it'd be very interesting and probably
quite important to try and
to get more insight into this so
hopefully you've learned something
in this video and as always thanks for
listening